JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS
WORLD."
I'M JESSE WATTERS.
THE UNCIVIL LEFT.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF WATERS
WORDS.
SECRETARY SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS
AND HER FAMILY WERE REFUSED
SERVICE AT THE RED HEN IN
VIRGINIA.
THE OWNERS ONLY IN THE KICKED
THEM OUT, BUT FOLLOWED THEM TO
ANOTHER RESTAURANT AND
TO SHOW UP.
IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN A RESTAURANT, IN A
DEPARTMENT STORE, AT A GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
CREATE A CROWD.
AND YOU PUSH BACK ON THEM.
AND YOU TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT
WELCOME.
JESSE: THIS EPISODE SPLIT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN LEFT.
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI
CONDEMNED HER BUT THE HARD LEFT
WANTS TO GET ROUGH.
IF YOU AND'.
ARE STANDING AT THE BORDER.
IT'S THE EEFLTNESS OF DONALD
SHE IS BEING RAPED.
ARE YOU A RAPIST?
>> PEOPLE VOTED FOR HIM AFTER
DONALD TRUMP WERE RACIST?
>> IF REPUBLICANS WEREN'T SO
CONSERVATIVE TO BE ON THEIR
SIDE.
>> THOSE PEOPLE SUPPORTING WHAT
HE'S DOING HERE ARE RACIST,
PERIOD.
>> THOSE MOVE 79S SHOULD BE
NON-VIOLENT, BUT THEY SHOULD NOT
BE NON-CONFRONTATIONAL.
JESSE: THEY ARE SAYING IF YOU
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP YOU ARE AN
BEEN AROUND BEFORE DONALD TRUMP
THE HEAT.
>> FOX NEWS!
FOX NEWS!
>> HE WANTS TO SHUT DOWN THE
COMMUNICATION.
THE TEACHER WAS GIVING ME THE
BUSINESS YESTERDAY AND THE
TEACHER TOLD ME SHE HATES ME
BECAUSE IT MAKES HER FEEL GOOD.
JESSE: THE BOTTOM LINE IS
EVERYONE SHOULD BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT IN THIS COUNTRY.
FOX NEWS, CNN, IF YOU LIKE